[Music]
subject for today
[Music]
oh oh that sounded more like a white
noise wow
it's a michael keaton classic is that an
angry slap
by the way for relaxation i don't have a
coaster here it's going to ruin my fine
pine table
which is actually the cheapest and
softest of woods but someone can send
in a coaster because this is all i have
glad to be with you today
we have a lot to get to my half agent
lawyer bill richmond is not here i
believe he's in his deposition but audio
wade is here
quarter black garrett is here hey how
are you gerald i'm doing well how are
you
that's nice but she makes me throw up in
my mouth a little because she's too cute
we're going to be talking about hunter
biden
and not just hunter biden but joe biden
because you know listen
the apple doesn't fall too far from the
tree and that's concerning
when the apple is a pedophile wow
what kind of a tree creates pedophile
apples
so there's some new unearthed evidence
and we can't show we cannot show you of
course the actual videos or images
because
we're not netflix this isn't cuties but
it has been corroborated
it is is there an issue going on there
uh tim from hr he's
taking care of there's a little bit of
technical difficulties going on here
today um but first
i think it's important to uh to hit this
story joe
biden and audio weight had said yes yeah
you told me
yeah that's something i know it's sort
of sad and uh also very funny
okay joe biden apparently they told me
not to watch it
yeah don't really look for jill biden's
reaction okay that joe biden
was uh not aware of whom he was running
against
what kind of country we're going to be
four more years of george
georgia he uh is going to find ourselves
in a position where
if uh trump gets elected uh we're gonna
be uh we're gonna be in a different
world
[Music]
she looks like she looks like watson
when he needs to stab
sherlock with an epinephrine yeah yeah
exactly i was thinking she was just
opening her mouth like a fish just like
oh
that is painful i can't believe i i
i had sex with you several times oh no
and then gave birth to a pedophile like
damien oh
it is like damien
um almost exactly we'll also be talking
by the way about joe biden i think he
may have lost pennsylvania
with his uh opinions his ex i don't even
know if they're bad i don't know if
they're his opinions that's the issue i
don't know what he believes
but his position on fracking position on
phasing out all energy
and aoc was on with uh jake tapper
yesterday
after twitch streaming uh
talking about her support for joe biden
and i was very confused
and then i realized that everything she
said was a lie so
we'll be going through that that does
explain and going through the lies from
aoc and joe biden and their lies on
fracking and their lies and green energy
and their lies in the fossil fuel
industry and their positions
uh they're in including all of the above
so it's hard to keep track of that'll be
fun
it's a lot of lies to correct here's the
thing a lot of people say it and i get
it's easy to become exhausted
sure yeah it's very easy to become
exhausted to get burnout
and how do you how do you know down from
up how do you keep
track of it here's the thing um how i
have an aunt who works in an insane
asylum
and it's she feels that way every day
that's what you just have to do it
leading up to election
[Applause]
day that's not your job i remember i
went in and i saw some like that's the
guy did you realize that he used to
actually be uh he was a former head
of of the department of education she
was no that's not true
like what she was no no he was a
squeegee guy and then he shot a hobo
uh yeah so he's here now like so he was
never ahead of the department of
education she goes no no you can't
believe anything they say
that's the joe biden campaign that's
true well that's if he wins that's the
next four years
exactly uh also um
sadly uh before we move on talking about
this um
the samsung chairman lee kim he
uh died yesterday yeah and uh we
actually um
warning we do have footage of his uh
untimely demise
samsung electronics was founded in 1969.
the same year when neil armstrong set
foot
on the month it does not
start well no
wow he was sad at least he he he died
doing what he loved
imitating his phones yeah that is tragic
he used to walk around going ring ring
yeah
hey he walked around for halloween
dressed as a galaxy seven
like there's a call answer it they're
like no we're not
we're not going to answer it because i
know you're going to blow me up no no i
i promise this time i'm not going to
blow you up i don't know i started off
yeah you went a little bit
answer the phone firecrackers go on
but we'll get it right next time um by
the way
uh please do we're gonna going to
continue here really quickly talking
about joe biden and the controversy with
hunter biden and his son
uh but first please do consider
following me on instagram that's we have
a lot of stuff going on if you like
stuff with uh the joe lewis and betty
and uh non-politics related stuff and of
course uh we will be taking your live
chat
when we go exclusive to mug club this
morning mug club everyone else here
step up here you all sound like someone
died what is the dirge
how much do you how many of the hunter
biden bombshells
do you really think that any of this
will stick and if i were advising
the presidential trump uh president
trump campaign yeah i would never
mention hunter biden without mentioning
joe biden
absolutely not about hunter biden it is
about joe biden about the leverage on
joe biden
it is about joe biden knowingly being
involved with these business practices
and at the very least knowing of all the
nefarious activity
and doing nothing if silence is violence
actual silence when your son is engaging
in sexual assault of minors allegedly is
uh i think legally accessory to actual
sexual violence
but you can't fit that on a bumper
sticker it's tough to do that yeah and
every single news outlet right now is
saying you're picking on hunter biden
that's all you're doing right now this
makes no
difference and no
that's not true though we're not trying
to pick on hunter biden we're trying to
point out no
we want to decide right exactly he is
he's he has a lot of douchebaggery in
his history right um that's that's
nothing
that's not the meanest thing you could
say about honor biden no is that he has
a lot of douche baggery
no it's not no no no i mean i'm trying
to encompass all of it you know yeah
you were asked like i don't know if you
were about to join the knights of
columbus and someone without you from
like
sure think about that hunter biden the
one guy you know he's a jerk
wouldn't be as powerful as you know he's
a corrupt foreign entity pedophile
who smokes crack naked in front of young
girls
including maybe or maybe not his niece
also
not so nice yeah also yeah i think
douchebaggery covers it that's about
right
not fun at parties i always assume that
pedophiles
i always assumed they were charming
because of what what you know the
grooming required
yeah but no turns out not when you're
the vice president's son but it does
seem like
trump is taking the tack of always
mentioning joe with hunter i don't i
haven't seen him talk about hunter bite
in the debate that we watched yeah he
only said
you and your family which is smart that
was a great idea yeah
just saying that he needs to clean it up
i think that's the perfect way to play
this like don't you don't have to make
accusations the the media is going to do
that in some respects for you
right now like the new york post and
something right and that's actually what
we're going to get to because joe biden
just asked recently
and here was his answer uh when finally
someone tried to
uh request some accountability okay uh
mr blind if i can um
questions the controversy continues
today about under buying your sons
there is no controversy it's a flat lie
because the president has nothing
else to run on if you notice while
american people are talking about
what's happening to their families he
has no plan and the debate he has no
plan
everything from the wall street journal
every other major
news outlet has said what he's saying is
simply not true
about my son but it's it's classic trump
classic trump what do you mean you mean
this wall street journal
this fall right here that one like this
is amazing to me because yes
most major media outlets have tried to
simply sweep this under the rug
but i wonder if joe biden had actually
he's so
incapable of thinking on his feet i
wonder if he had just
read the wall street journal article
confirming authenticating
some of these texts some of these emails
that have recently been unloaded but i
can't believe that
pratt at wall street journal would do me
like that and so then he's on stage
this isn't corroborated by any major
news and in his head he's going
pick one anyone but the wall street
journal anyone but the wall street
journal anyone
who's a wall street journal even says
it's not true
he's just pulling from a short file pick
new york times
washington post abc nbc cnn anything
but the one well stephen you're just
making fun of his stutter and that's
cruel
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and he misspoke
the thing is like miriam webster updated
stutter to
and they have synonym lying
[Laughter]
yeah ultimately someone getting was
getting in trouble for calling him
stuttering joe i don't remember who it
was yeah
and to their credit they didn't
apologize but like sure as soon as this
thing i just no he doesn't have a
stutter
no yeah it's no it's not true that's not
true
doctor is respected i don't respect him
i don't like him i don't like him i
think he should be fired but
listen send your letters to uh
info with credit.com ask atlanta and ask
for your apology
and i will be sure to get right on not
answering you so
the wall street journal did confirm uh
some of the new york post reporting but
what were they
confirming they're also confirming some
new info if you didn't tune in to this
uh
conference before the debate you
probably want to write this for the
debate tony babilinski so he's hunt
hunter biden's past business partner
yeah okay
um he gave a press conference
corroboring the biden laptop so he was
saying i know that that is true
uh the emails that were in new york post
was people are saying we can't
authenticate because they never actually
tried
and then he submitted three additional
new phones
full three phones uh-oh and you know
phones they ha
they they like i think the lowest iphone
now is like 128 gigs
that's a lot of pictures that could be
incriminated yeah and i mean even if
i just don't i don't think he's using 4k
so as long as it's 720
there can be days of footage um
any uh he handed these phones over the
fbi and senate here is a clip from that
press conference
i've heard joe biden say that he's never
discussed business with hunter
that is false i have firsthand knowledge
about this because i directly dealt with
the biden family including joe biden
tomorrow i will be meeting with the
senate committee members concerning this
matter
and i will be providing to the fbi the
devices which contain
the evidence corroborating what i have
said
so i will not be taking any questions at
this time i'm pretty sure he was wearing
a corset
yeah there was a lot of did you notice
so it came down and then this was either
was a bulletproof vest or it was a
corset
but that doesn't change the validity
what is on the phones
don't get sidetracked it's not about the
corset
maybe it's about or
the main takeaway here is is again it's
not just about hunter biden but about
joe biden being involved confirming that
the big guy mentioned this in these
emails who's being cut in on the
financial deals
is in fact joe biden and that they have
had involvement
uh with chinese business partnerships
this is
this is something that's really
important especially when you look at
the policies of joe biden the obama
administration
with china and how that hurt the
american worker that is incredibly
relevant
by the way pennsylvania fracking is
going to be gone
all fossil fuels will be gone you know
that all mining is going to be gone no
more coal
and uh hey also we're gonna send the
rest of the manufacturing jobs to china
because uh
hunter biden uh well there are a few
pictures circulating
and joe can't have that going around so
right let's just have another tpp oh
this this guy coming out
i mean this is massive because you may
choose not to believe that emails are
real but this guy coming out and saying
look i worked with these guys
first hand day in day out i understand
what's going on here's the evidence by
the way to corroborate what i'm saying
how do you get around that like there's
just there's unless he's absolutely flat
out lying you just you can't walk
around that like
vaccine being tested on kids as young as
12. hunter biden goes
huh do you mean like every vaccine
look at this look at this right now
bring can we bring this up full screen
real quick cnn look
every single thing on scene right now is
designed to scare you total cases
deaths fees are vaccine being tested as
young as 12.
we're going in for a bleak winter a dark
winter bun
no no no no no no no there you go this
guy with the mustache who i'm sure is on
hunter biden's laptop somewhere
jeff he's one of those kids 225 000.
and you're including 90 year olds with
diabetes and coronary heart disease
that's not that bad not saying that
every life isn't valuable you're the
party of death
not us but this is certainly the party
of fear
and you know i have to step it up oh
yeah because because things in this
country
have been pretty good listen the last
four years outside of the riots and that
kind of
you know that's on you guys it's been
pretty good
drug costs have gone down wages have
gone up
unemployment is down black people feel
pretty good about donald trump it's been
pretty good so we have to scare people
with 225 000 dead over the course of a
year in separate flu seasons just
totaling
all people who have had coveted at time
of death and can you believe that
they're testing vaccines
on 12 year olds well how do you think
they tested vaccines for diseases that
actually
affected 12 year olds yeah well the
reason the reason that they
are stepping it up is because trump is
right and we're learning to live with it
right we're actually learning how to
figure out how to deal with this virus
we're getting back to the terms
better so hospitalizations are going
down the length of stay in hospitals is
going down the severity of symptoms is
going down
death rate is going down everything is
tracking pretty well
spikes in cases are gonna happen that's
just how these things work there's
nothing you can do about that except
lock yourself in a basement like joe
biden and we don't all have that benefit
people talk about this job
okay people say what's your plan what is
your plan yeah specifically what is
specifically your plan
donald trump made sure that we have more
testing available he's operation warp
speed so we can move along therapeutics
treatments so that we can have more ways
that people can get back to work that we
can have some kind of financial
security for those who are most oh biden
do a lot lockdown
last time you said lockdown and mask
mandate by the way mask mandate on all
federal high all federal roads really in
your
car because you can give yourself
federal land public land
and then in the roads what we're going
to field walking
down the roads cars
[Laughter]
my shadows the only one that walks
beside me
right come on man half the time you know
the show
you know the thing robert plant
all right so let's move back to hunter
biden he's totally all there
um now there are multiple recent
alleged hunter biden sex tapes ooh yeah
if you're gonna
post it online over the weekend right um
okay so we have to be care again we're
not netflix we can't show cuties
uh so we will not show this and nor
would i
incur no would i encourage you to go and
look this up i do know that there are
videos available
and when i say allegedly um it's pretty
clear hunter biden is in there and it's
pretty clear these things are really
awful and it seems very much like these
people are underage especially when
you when combined with the other
evidence at hand
and now the website by the way with
these videos or some of the more of
these leaks is run by a chinese
businessman who is a friend of uh
i believe steve bannon so i want to make
sure people ah bannon is like okay but i
don't know if
even if you don't like steve bannon and
breitbart like he didn't stage
yeah a pedophile sex tape yeah
so it's crying it's still yeah hunter
biden is still in
him it's steve bannon standing in the
kitchen like have a seat
i was i was just getting something to
eat i was making some doritos you know
yes i eat my mcdoubles naked
and what do you do sir i'm a computer
technician they're always competing
that's weird and there is something
that's trending over there i don't know
if it's 4chan of those sites where
apparently in one of these videos
they're trying to estimate the size of
of uh of hunter biden's john thomas
because there are m
m's so again just to give an idea of the
graphic details
on hunter biden's johnson some people
are trying to balance them but that
being said
jokes on you they're m minis oh
oh no that's a jury i hate those things
so he knew about the cameras
he knew about the cameras he did the
anthony weiner space odyssey angle and
he just said no
i'll put on minis they'll be none the
wiser she'll got my balancing again
people thought you know what say what
you want about hunter biden
he's a crack addled pedophile who
used his position and his father's
influence for ill-gotten gain
but a huge schmeckle and then you find
out none of that
yeah none of that is true it's all for
perspective coming down
the house of eminem mini cards that's
tragic
yeah that's really bad these are so this
is just so that you guys know there's
more out there than just oh we think
there might be some kind of a picture
i don't want anyone to run across this
and i don't know the legal liability of
anyone out there i felt like i
i felt like the feds might kick in my
door
like i like like beauty and the beast
with a giant log because i previewed
cuties for this show well you just look
at the poster that's all you have to do
with
i thought like i don't know if someone
would ever say like you've ever seen
child pornography i would have to say
well
i saw cuties and like take me away they
zip tie me
netflix 2020 sorry they lost like 800
000 subscribers i love it
biggest on wall street for them ever
giuliani uh did say and he was on
i think one of him he was on a news
channel i don't want to get it wrong uh
yeah
he was the one who said that there are
salacious pictures of underage girls on
the hard drive and
again he this is something that has been
confirmed by multiple sources but here
he is talking about the
more recent evidence fallacious pictures
of underage girls
meaning underage girls uh scantily clad
which is a nice way i can say it and in
one case
nude at the top i believe the girl was
15.
wow okay but he tucked in his shirt in a
borad interview oh yeah
he can't believe a guy who tucked in his
shirt totally morally equivalent yeah
totally morally equivalent between
crap 15 year olds and he had a text that
he showed uh i think i don't know it was
accidentally we saw it on the screen
let's bring this up really quickly
there was a text from hunter biden being
sent and uh this is so this is there's a
well-known track record of this where he
said
she told my therapist that i was
sexually inappropriate with
and there are some allegations as to who
this is but a 14 year old girl
whom he might have with whom he might be
very close let's put it that way you can
do your own research
so he says she told my therapist that i
was sexually inappropriate with this
girl
when she says that i face time naked
with her and the reason i can't have her
out to see me is because i'll walk
around naked smoking crack
talking to girls on facetime well you
know what um
i don't know if that person has a
problem that should qualify for mom of
the year award
i mean probably pretty out there though
because
we're setting a low bar i don't care
this is
really well well listen if you're if
you're face timing someone else
naked while smoking crack and there's a
14 year old or 15 year old in the
room yeah call call me old-fashioned yes
i still have a problem with your
old-fashioned stephen and this is being
said by the way
these kinds of textbooks are being sent
between family members
therapists so it's not like this idea
that people were not aware of it so yeah
let me let me offer something else to
you and then i want to go to you
let me offer up something else to you
this is at the very least
uh awful be likely criminal sexually
predatory
okay certainly doing drugs this is a
person who is causing damage hunter
biden wherever he goes himself
uh now let's put aside the business
dealings with his father the big guy and
the money being cut in which is the real
scandal here
if you are the vice president or if
you've been in office for 48
years and you know there's someone out
there who is
buying potentially dealing drugs
potentially providing them to underage
people potentially engaging in sexual
activity
with 14 or 15 year olds at what point do
we judge you for your
lack of action considering your power
yeah hey it's your son
it's your son your son is abusing
allegedly
young girls joe biden why don't you do
anything is that the moral thing
my son deals with his own problems this
reminds me of when i was a kid reminds
me of a story um we had these kids who
we used to carpool with
and johnny boy knows the story so uh we
used to carpool with these kids they
were friends of the family they lived
right down near a block
but they were also you know kids really
wanted to be cool fickle my brother at
one point
they didn't like my brother for some
reason he was making he's this is like
back when new thug was a thing he'd be
like yo what up homie g
and because they actually thought they
were fat from greenfield park canada
they got upset
and they wanted to beat up my brother
but instead my brother was bigger and
could beat them up so they decided to
follow me home and beat me up
oh okay and then one day when i wasn't
at school i was recording arthur okay
so my dad went to the bus stop to pick
up my brother we were waiting and we saw
my brother and my friend johnny boy get
out of the bus stop
and we saw 12 kids following them
finally the homie g guy got his buddies
and these were kids who we carpooled
with yeah they were cowards they were a
family of cowards
and so we watched them follow my brother
and john and them duck into
a blocked parent's house and my father
called their mother
and said do you have any idea what's
going on she said well well i let my son
fight his own battles that's like joe
biden
she said i let my son fight his own
battles you know what my dad said my dad
said okay absolutely so we're going to
lock your son
and jordan in a racquetball court i have
a reservation on saturday we'll see who
comes out
how could you how could you do that i
don't encourage violence he said no
no you just said you let your kids solve
your own problems i don't let my son get
beaten up by gangs of 12 cowards
i will let them settle it with their
fists which is what your son plan on
doing
only another 11 pairs of fists alone in
a racquetball club
are we good and she thought my father
was a monster the same thing joe biden
saying i let my son solve his own
problems
he's a sexual criminal and predator he
hurts
every life he touches and you were in a
position of power
to do something about it joe were you
too busy sniffing your own six-year-old
yeah well
and this debauched lifestyle was propped
up by a job that
his dad got him gave him yeah so joe
biden guaranteed that he kept
and had this job all this money he spent
on again
right sex what sex trafficked girls all
of this money
against lifestyle is it's joe biden's
fault it does reflect on joe biden it's
not just trying to character assassinate
him because of his kid
right it is it does reflect negatively
on him he didn't get caught smoking weed
at a most deaf concert
right exactly right listening to tupac
you know in college
um basically he has put himself in a
position where he said i am the moral
candidate compared to donald trump this
is joe biden right so he's opened this
door
into my morality versus his morality
right his morality is he says things
about women that we all detest
sometimes and his morality is that he's
done some things that probably
we wouldn't do on the other hand your
morality and your family's morality is
on center stage right now yeah and the
only thing that news is talking about is
coronavirus because
the only thing you know better on right
now i'm tired of this where people act
as oh the real criminals are the big
banks listen
i'm against the big banks who support
joe biden i'm against big banks i'm
against big auto
against big oil i'm against subsidies
i'm against unfair business practices
across the board okay
i want to be clear but people say those
people are they're roman free words
we're locking up people of color no
listen
there is a difference between someone
cheating on their taxes and someone
looking somebody else in the eye
and committing sexual assault against a
minor there is a difference between
okay listen you know what uh i didn't
pay i put some money in the cayman
islands or in panama
and stabbing somebody knocking over a
liquor store i'm sorry there is a
difference there is a difference because
there are a lot of people here who if
you can get away
with some kind of a tax break or if you
can get away
with paying less than you have to or if
you can get away with i don't know
maybe getting another free ice cream
cream cone using the coupon twice or
maybe like i did at halloween in
chipotle where i dressed up as a burrito
two different burritos one with a mask
so i got two burritos the point is not
even
perfect but there's a huge difference
between that
and the kind of crime we are talking
about the clintons and the biden family
and let me finish here this is really
important because
um they talk about well what about what
about donald trump's kids
you know what what about donald trump's
kids let's go
through that that is kind of one thing
that is remarkable to me no one's
perfect
right no drug scandals no sexual assault
scandals with the kids
i mean people want to say oh they made
money off their dad's name well it's in
the private sector so it's not your tax
dollar so i don't have much of a problem
with it it seems like they actually work
pretty damn hard
also then rape kids let's be clear let's
say that
maybe donald trump jr used some leverage
while his dad was working the private
sector
to yeah have a leg up in business i
think he's been pretty straightforward
about that but you know what else
donald trump senior president trump is a
teetotaler
donald trump jr just last time on this
show said
i don't drink and he said the reason for
that is not that i don't like drinking
is that i wasn't particularly good at
drinking and what does the media do
oh he used to be an alcoholic he used
about an alcoholic well why don't we why
don't we focus on the redemption oh
that's right because there is no
redemption with the bidens
there is nothing he's still apparent
right yeah
go ahead yeah the the nerve of the media
too because the media has
he's been asked about hunter biden twice
and
and in one of the cases he stepped on
the question didn't let the person
finish
and said there is no controversy right
so he he actually knows that people that
he will not get a follow-up question
yeah nobody else is going to get cut off
right here and then
joe biden call a lid at 10 a.m
yeah with what are we eight days to
election now are we eight or nine days
to election right now
eight eight days call a lid at 11 a.m
and the
and the people are terrified right in
the media because they all act as though
the media is terrified of donald trump
right but we wait i guess
we might get a white house press pass
but with joe biden
if anyone even wants to ask this
question like uh hey yeah um
i wanted to ask you about uh about uh
the scout with the hunter about the
the the lap uh the lap the hunter the
the lap uh what's your favorite cherry
[Laughter]
they are terrified because you know what
donald trump doesn't have control over
the press
because they all hate him you know who
does
the guy who was part of the
administration to to
to whose cocktail parties you
desperately wanted to be invited
they are terrified they are terrified of
asking these ques
questions of joe biden could you imagine
could you imagine
if one of us here turned up had pictures
like this and
underage sex scandals do you think that
i i would expect to not have any
questions
asked i've had questions act be asked
because we had a shirt
with fig leaves on them yes
you took far more scrutiny than joe
biden has for hunter biting over that
a funny shirt a funny shirt yeah to have
no accountability whatsoever yeah
these are as about as bad as individual
actions can get
from hunter biden as a person which is
dad could have stopped but maybe
maybe we have the answer maybe he didn't
because joe biden was making too many
dollar dollar bills yeah and that's what
people
need to follow and you have to do it
yourself you cannot rely on the media to
do it for you because they won't
well and this should be i mean i don't
care where you stand on the political
spectrum i don't care if you're a biden
supporter a trump supporter
this should be a story that is
investigated and all we've seen is the
media cover for him
and change the subject but then we had
50 intelligence people come out and sign
a document that the media said said that
this was all russian collusion
no what it said or russian
disinformation what it said was this has
all the earmarks and even if it isn't
this we should treat it as though it is
right
that's what it said yeah can you imagine
by the way these weren't posit people in
position no
power to actually confirm or deny the
people who were not doing a lot of
people who don't like donald trump
this is not the russians that's not
totally this is this is hunter biden uh
doing his thing yeah think of this for a
second it is less far-fetched
to believe that a formerly sitting vice
president and current favorite to win
the presidency
has a crack addicted pedophile
sex tape with underage potentially
allegedly relatives
son then uh donald trump being involved
with russia
that's how far we are because we know
there's zero possibility of donald trump
being involved with russia well we've
known for a long time that the news is
basically two different silos the people
are in their right wing kind of silo in
the left-wing sort of silo
but this is the clearest example of
something that is being totally ignored
right there yeah i think i think there
used to be at least a couple different
interpretations of the facts or we'll
talk about it less
i i really i haven't seen it covered at
all
in the left-wing media it's it's uh it's
an insane thing and it is number one
that's why i think
joe biden listed the wall street journal
as denying its authenticity because it's
the only source that was
talking about it right i was like oh
this looks to be real he's like oh i
can't believe it
i even uh all the papers said it's not
legitimate which paper joe
uh wall street journal that's the only
one that said it is
if it was don jr it would be on the news
24
7 all day long every second you turn on
every any channel it would be
if don junior kissed a 12 year old on
the cheek oh yeah
it would be it would be way smaller
whatever joe biden was using their
forehead like a cr like a scratch and
sniff
and then his son was using their hip
bones for the for banging crack rocks
yeah well put it this way what if uh
what if hunter biden was amy coney
barrett's son
with the stuff that we just went through
do you think that that question would
have come up in the senate hearing yeah
do you think that the democrats would
have been well
you mean do i i see that you're son
you're unfair do i think
senator hirono who asked have you ever
committed sexual assault
or unwanted sexual advances do i think
she would have brought up
anything if her children didn't have a
spotless record yeah i think they would
have brought up the k
if the kid was suspended for playing on
an iphone in school yeah
it just goes to show that any kind of
moral you know z snapping that these
people do
is all fake it's all an act they don't
care about morality they just care about
power
right what is z-snapping well it's kind
of like sassy
oh i'm just picturing heroin it really
is it would be an
s z would mean rigid like a white person
like
like yeah with no rhythm
i'm sorry just like little pump who
endorsed donald trump right yeah
by the way a little bit of aoc
uh hit the notification bell though if
you were subscribed uh
so because subscribers don't mean a
whole lot basically they don't really
mean a whole lot i'm subscribed to other
channels and i don't know what it does
[Music]
i don't know where to find them so i
just have to search them all the time
and i know that you can't find us when
you search us
so hit the notification bell because we
stream good morning mug club every
morning monday through thursday at 10
a.m eastern and
next week tuesday election night
coverage our biggest
huge uh live stream ever it could be 10
hours could be 12 it could be 15 hours
and we will have all your favorite
guests ted cruz and
donald trump jr and all the people who
you want to see also uh
apparently i am going to be shot in a
chest with a bulletproof vest
are you yeah cause we have a new sponsor
coming in okay i didn't know about this
live oh okay live
this this could be interesting let's
start looking for a new yeah well no
i'll be fine i'll be fine that's why
it's the sponsor it's bulletproof vest
so
with a gun yes what else do you shoot
somebody with a bulletproof vest on with
no i mean an arrow or no with a with a
heart
with an rpg i think it'll work i don't
know this is sorry i'm a little slow i
don't i don't know maybe i don't know
hopefully the bullet should be
a little faster than you but not too
fast
not too fast dodge it just dodge it you
can dodge it yeah by the way just to
just in case you're ever wondering uh
don't believe people in authority just
because of their authority because i
knew a kid in school who said that he
had dodged
bullets he said he could dodge bullets
there's no way that's not true and the
kid was
the kid was clearly lying and i said i
said miss mary he's clearly lying i just
made up that name because i don't want
to i don't
want to out for the innocent involved
and uh she said well what does he i said
he said he can dodge a bull he's dodged
a bullet that's not possible she's like
well
yeah he can't did you dodge a bullet and
he said yes she said well then
he's telling the truth
the whole trust falls that's how we got
to 2020 man but the kid is
clearly lying and i also had a teacher
tell me that the earth was not spinning
very fast or we would all spin off
ah this is canadian education or
deliberate education which one
[Laughter]
there's a direct line you could you can
trace between that teacher saying oh
yeah he
he can dodge bullets to 2020. right
where he gets shot trying to dodge a
bullet is that what you're saying
yeah a lot of challenges here's another
one uh i had a kid
a guy named daniel steal my pens my dad
worked for a company yeah
and uh his name was on the pens and i
those were the only pens that i had you
know he saved my hand back to school
shopping he stole my pen so all my pens
are gone like 15 pens with my dad's name
on them
like daniel stole my pens the guy's name
was monsieur like i don't care he was a
gym teacher so then he was teaching
english temporarily so that is his
actual name
but you're like she's like yeah yeah you
stole my pens he goes really how do you
know
well because those are my pens and you
know ah they're my pens and i said well
actually my dad works for that company
and uh my dad's name is on those pens
darren crowder you see his name i'm
steven crowder i think and then he goes
no
my dad works for that company and i said
okay but why would my dad's names be
printed on the pens
and the teacher goes you know what if
you two can't settle it
no one gets depends no no no
not a moral equivalency if you two can't
learn to work it out
this is the point yeah yeah this is the
point sometimes
good can't work it out with evil
including evil daniel
who stole my father's pens there is no
like that the united states
is the one when people act like the u.n
they talk about like well the united
states no that's the u.n where all of
you can't
settle it no no no no no no no no hamas
has
destruction of all jews and it's charter
yeah it's not the same thing where's it
don't work with it you put down your
weapons we'll put down our weapons the
united states
is the teacher who comes in and goes
come on cut the [ __ ] daniel it has his
name
no you can't yeah the bank taylor says
it's his money the bank robber says it's
his money
if you two can't work it out nobody gets
the money government gets the money
if you in the pantsuit and you and the
ski mask can't find
some kind of common ground
[Laughter]
hold hands that's why i don't believe in
finding common ground if it's not found
on truth okay speaking of untruth uh so
this next one
i don't know about you and you guys let
me know i think i i have a gut feeling
that donald trump could win this thing
it's still
50 50 and you need to go out like and
vote like your life depends on it
oh yeah um if you're in pennsylvania
vote twice after election haha kidding
don't fat check i'm not encouraging
anyone to commit a crime
that's a joke just vote for your
deadness it's a joke
don't do that but it may be possible so
we'll leave it to you
with joe biden this is something that
even democrats are distancing themselves
from him where he
tried to say well yeah we're going to
phase out all fossil fuels yeah
um which isn't really the problem is
he's just
so good at pissing off everybody because
the far left people he's not doing
enough
right and then somehow he took a
steaming dump on everyone in
pennsylvania yeah
uh and um and i think that was one of
donald trump's best moments oh yeah
pennsylvania are you listening texas are
you listening yeah because i think
this is one thing people talk about
undecided voters because we know them
like functionally [ __ ] people at
this point if you're undecided
it's also by the way why you should have
to vote the day of because a lot can
change
yeah yes um but i think donald trump
created a new swath of undecided i don't
think it has anything to do with
undecided voters i think there were
people who were going to go in and vote
for joe biden and
they went in and said but i know i'm
going to lose my job
yeah yeah if not tomorrow certainly by
the end of 40 and if it's eight
i'm definitely out of a job all right i
gotta vote donald trump i think that
that
seriously could have fundamentally
changed the numbers of registered
democrats yes when people talk about
blue dog democrats sort of the reagan
coalition
i mean could you think of a more clear
example of people like that than people
in the midwestern states who work in
fossil fuels or fracking which has
created an entire
entire an entirely energy independent
nation the united states
do you think i can't think of any more
clear example of what would turn those
people
over to voting for donald trump other
than knowing that uh joe biden will
literally take their guns away but no
one's covering that yeah and it's forced
him to spend money
uh in that state where he could be using
that in other states if you look at all
the swing states there's only one state
that joe biden has visited more times
than donald trump and that's
pennsylvania
and so he's forced him he's boxing he's
going to go back to amy's death well no
he just he doesn't want to travel very
far and then pennsylvania's close right
so he he has boxed him into campaigning
there
almost exclusively and trump is in all
these other states
like sometimes twice as many visits
right and not spending nearly as much
money in those states because he's got
to spend a ton of money in pennsylvania
it's crazy
he's going around it's like the the
santa claus yeah the way donald trump is
going around in three four five rounds
you're like
yeah he's just going three four a day he
just flies at the airport
yeah exactly and a carrot for the pilot
well no
no biden's flip-flopping on fracking is
a good example of why he's going to be
very useful if he gets
in office for the left because they can
again just use him for whatever purpose
he wants
pull him in whatever direction yeah he
has no core convictions he's the
chauncey gardener
of the left yeah and by the way we'll be
uh once we leave youtube we'll be taking
your chat exclusively please
um okay so here's a good point with that
is aoc was interviewed uh on
on jake tapper i was watching this
yesterday and uh yeah i watch it so you
get
sunday morning so i get skelter then i
get jake tapper
and then i get uh fareed zekka uh
not the one with the bad haircut sanjay
gupta the other one oh okay
so anyway yeah yeah is that yeah
i thought it was a drug dealer every
sunday morning and i watched aoc on
there with jake dapper and ooh this
shows you the riff that is happening
with the left
and just how bad the democratic party is
for the united states of america so here
is
crazy eyes ao
uh talking about joe biden uh being
against a fracking ban vice president
biden has made
very clear that he does not agree with a
fracking ban
and i consider that a you know it will
be a privilege to lobby him
well you also don't think we should have
lobbyists and you wanted money out of
politics so
crazy by the way also uh this comes from
uh americans for tax reform joe biden of
course said that he supported a fracking
ban many many many many many many man
no more no new fracking we are
we are going to get rid of fossil fuels
like what about say
stopping cracking and stopping would
there be any place for fossil fuels
including coal and fracking in the biden
administration
no it would be we would we would work it
out we would make sure it's eliminated
guarantee we're going to end fossil fuel
he is pretty clear it was a guarantee no
ability for the oil industry to continue
to drill
period ends number one three consecutive
american presidents have enjoyed
stints of explosive economic growth due
to a boom in oil and natural gas
production
as president would you be willing to
sacrifice some of that growth
even knowing potentially that it could
displace thousands maybe hundreds of
thousands of blue-collar workers
in the interest of transitioning to that
greener economy the answer is yes just
to be clear all of that is not enough
for aoc
aoc is saying he's clearly against
fracking
i don't know what's political expediency
at this point none of what these people
say are true for all the for all of the
problems you have
with donald trump and i have many too
you pretty much know that what he says
he's going to do he's going to do and
sometimes he's like
i don't know if you should do that but
he said he is so he already box himself
he's going to have to do it
and we're going to have funny hat
tuesday be a national holiday yeah
even when he does uh even when donald
trump does the art of the deal thing
where he talks past it and then
gives himself room to negotiate back it
is the same direction
right yeah just the opposite right no
exactly um
so but that's not enough for aoc and
here's something that's interesting now
aoc has changed her tune was
what was that pack that the young turks
uh uh uh
reg can probably tell me or someone
there can maybe maddie reg can
what was the name of the pack for the
from the young justice democrats justice
democrats
aoc was a justice democrat candidate
where she was the one who was supposed
to go in and oust the old
democrats right that was your whole
thing yeah but uh now she's saying that
young activists are actually
disciplined and aren't voting for their
favorite person but she's explaining why
it'll be a good thing now for young
people to not vote for radical democrats
like justice democrats like aoc and
bernie
sanders but the guy who's been in office
for 48 years and
opposed desegregation and busing here
you go
people right now have a very disciplined
activist mindset and
they are not here with the intent of
voting for their favorite person
or voting for uh you know someone that
they think is perfect
they believe that they want to vote for
a president that is at least going to be
receptive
uh to their advocacy activism
huh um so basically
biden it'll do
well yeah and receptive to their
advocacy is just like
puppet yeah basically you know like
honestly here's the thing is i don't
i mean i don't i've had a real i can't
put my hand
up donald trump's ass and make him do
but with
he's actually receptive and i can say so
right so right so right so right and i
put on a little bit of lipstick and it's
it's senor biden and that is an act
that i can travel with so uh she's like
oh maybe
good enough just this time last year she
said that she'd be
damned if she let a politician like i
don't know
pulling a name out of thin air joe biden
uh take office
and i will be damned if the same
to politicians then are gonna try to
come back today
and say we need a middle of the middle
of the road approach to save our lives
that
is too much for me don't make fun of our
stutter
to save our lives i'll be damned
so sassy i guess that's just going jack
is ahead of you so there you go if
there's gonna be a joe biden type and
now she's like but we're also we're also
really disciplined because we understand
that
we only have a joe biden type so it's
this is this is
how damning the fossil fuel comments
were at this last debate and this is why
the media does not want to talk about it
it is campaign ending
and you can see everyone spinning their
wheels trying to get out of it now i
want to know people out there who work
in energy
what you think and if you have people
who maybe have changed their votes
because we have a lot of people who are
saying
that a lot of people across the country
um then she also talked about you know
of course fracking
so the science is in and fracking aoc
said it's far worse for the environment
just here's here's here's the clip
the science is very clear the methane
emissions from fracking are up to 64
times
more powerful than co2 emissions at
trapping heat in the air and just from
a perspective of stopping climate
climate change you know there is a
scientific consensus
okay uh none of that is true fracking is
far cleaner
is far cleaner people need to understand
that than most ways that we can actually
get any kinds of fossil fuels and the
whole consensus right she's trying to
say this consensus on fracking there
isn't even that's not even an argument
that you can make scientifically but
then the argument is there's scientific
consensus in general on climate change
the ninety seven percent
that's not a true number you can do a
lot of cloud.com we wrote about it it
was actually
uh uh a review was 97 study it was just
0.3 endorsement of the standard
definition of consensus
uh this is not something that is true
when people throw out 97
doesn't mean that most scientists don't
believe that there's some kind of
climate change yes
but the idea that the paris accord is
going to or sorry was it the paris
agreement montreal
protocol paris accord but that's going
to change it or the idea that fracking
is worse for the environment there is no
science on that
there is science to the opposite of that
fracking is safer
uh and also offshore drilling here in
the united states is safer
not only because they have well okay how
many
tanks do you think how many tanker ships
is that what they're called
tankers have spills in a given year
you're talking about
many tens of bring this up to humanity
many tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of tons of
oil that gets spilled because they're
traveling across the ocean
think about this for a second it's
traveling
across the ocean here's
here are the two processes we can have
when we're talking about energy and
we're talking about fracking and i know
i know i know you don't like any oil or
fossil fuel and i understand that but
the fact is we're not at
we're not at sunshine and farts yet
so right now we all know that we need to
transition off even joe biden said yeah
i'll ban it but we're gonna have to
work it out transition wow ah
so we're gonna build we all acknowledge
we have to transition so at this point
if we use any fossil fuels
what is the better way to get it from
other countries
saudi arabia countries in the middle
east where you know we have the epa
they have their comparable nothing they
don't use any standards at all
and then putting this oil on tankers
that have to cross
thousands of miles of ocean where it
makes the bp oil spill
look like a puddle that you may be
smiling under an old duckies
on the los angeles sidewalk that
day after day year after year or
a scientifically improved safer method
with fewer risks of contamination of
spillage
here in the united states that also
makes us energy independent so that we
don't support these countries who by the
way
beat the [ __ ] out of a woman if she
tries to drive stick
i can't even make it all the way to my
chair without spilling my coffee all
over myself and i can't
then they're having to transport gallons
of oil
you know it's actually a cleaner by the
way we talk about oil all the time with
fracking the biggest the abundant thing
is natural gas do you know what natural
gas does when you burn it
it's much cleaner than coal like much
much much the consensus is out on that
it is well there's much
stuff fracking fossil fuel the way that
we do it there are cleaner ways we even
moved upon them and by the way after we
go exclusively to mug club i'm going to
make the airtight case that i feel very
confident in that republicans
conservatism have actually done more for
the green energy sector and they are
better if you want to save the
environment than the democrats
um some of these reasons may surprise
you but hint it involves elon musk who i
believe is south african but he also
sounds like he could
be uh australian or just german i don't
know
i don't trust him he's mysterious but
he's a serious man uh
here's another claim that aoc made
trying to it's funny that she
the fact that she is being brought out
to spin for the biden campaign tells me
how desperate things right yeah
hey kenshi go out there and get on
twitch
yeah that's like we're gonna take some
call we're gonna take some calls from
other twitch gamers and just hunt her by
the exhale of the crap
that's a good head get get out of here
tammy get out of here tammy i don't want
the feds watching my twitch stream
i muted my camera she also said
this is one that's crazy no
no accountability she said that green
energy
was actually cheap and here's the thing
the argument right now is we can't
afford to just try and go
all the way to so like it's well
accepted that it's way more expensive
but people say well you know what
the earth is important right because
it's gone up 1.6 degrees over the last
century which you wouldn't determine in
the thermostat but
if we don't do something it's going to
be like terminator 2 when skynet falls
so we say that it's worth the extra
price but she
actually now is making the argument
which no scientists or economists will
undergird that green energy is cheaper
than fossil fuels and natural gas
the fact of the matter is is that if you
do believe in markets
solar and renewable energies are growing
less and less expensive
by the day and in many areas uh they are
starting to become less expensive than
fossil fuels
no by the way how many areas for people
who support the market
it's like when this is coming from
someone who never supports the market
right
like i get what you're about to do and
i've got you know what i've got my lie
detector ready and it's just called a
pencil and notepad
and to detect your life i just need to
rewrite it and go
that's exactly what i thought she said
solar wind energy are two to three times
more expensive than fossil fuels two to
three times more expensive
than fossil fuels it's not even close
and the reason for that is because of
government intervention and government
subsidies that have actually handicapped
the green
green energy industry and this is just
something that i want to hear from you
guys
if you think that this could have cost
buying the election
it would have cost buy in the election
if we had a media
who actually were critical even remotely
both candidates not only that remember
george h.w bush he had a look at his
watch moment that was a huge thing he
did yeah the paperwork oh it looked like
he was disinterested well biden was
looking at his watch just because he
wanted
he wanted to check his pulse he thought
he had died
and they don't mention this at all the
media you just see the contrast george
h.w bush
it was what lost in the election some
people would argue joe biden is not only
looking at his watch
they just flat out lying all the time
and now he's he's so
behind that he's putting a lid on all of
his campaigning days at 9
10 11. not even a good like not even
enough to do like a brunch
fundraiser and he's sending out aoc
effectively as a proxy that to me is a
sign of desperation we're going to be
talking more about green energy
and how republicans have done more for
green energy and conservatism than the
left foot
youtube we love you you can go go piss
off